usually what I try look for a role is
something I haven't done before I just I
like to sort of you know throw some
fresh stuff out and I think about well
how important is this character
full-stop not not how big but just how
important how how interesting is this
going to be to watch and bring to life
it's got to be about the writing it's
all it really does it's got to be about
the writing I suppose what I'm looking
for is to be intrigued in some way maybe
you have a question raised that that
isn't immediately answered for me it's
not often there necessarily the case
that that you'd realize that as you're
reading something it might be that of
the following a few days you know it's
percolating a really well tool narrative
is really important I think because
oftentimes when you're standing about a
film set rehearsing it's not really
rehearsing that you're doing it's
devising because everybody's doing that
what is this scene what are we doing and
it's because the narrative is sort of
forgotten for a little while sometimes I
think I've been a bit of a cherry picker
from that go
I was quite strict on myself about doing
jobs that would where I'd find out
something I'd never learned before
saying no is the only real control you
have over your career save mr. banks I
just adored the script and we just had
was a very beautiful script Akiva
Goldsman wrote very beautiful very
moving script and some of them you just
I mean you just like you read in Bruges
and it's it's just so remarkably unique
like nothing else but every job is
entirely different and you approach it
with the demands of that particular job
you know I'm pretty much open to
anything from the three-month you know
Mike Lee experience just jumping in if
the person in control has a kind of full
vision of what they're trying to do it's
a great thing to have rehearsals and
just know that you're you're coming at
it from the same point of view
it just means you could be more free you
can play and enjoy it and I think that's
what elevates good work - great work or
really exciting or daring work it seems
to be that a lot of the thoughts that
you have when just reading the script
you're not just learning lines
when you read in Skype together again
and again every time you read it you get
new ideas and you're writing down your
script so along with the words that
you're meant to be landing you're also
kind of remembering and learning these
notes and these scribbles and these
ideas in terms of the relationship
between actor and director I think that
they're really good the really good ones
somehow find a way to communicate
wordlessly their support for what you're
doing and not in a precious way they're
just glad you're there you know they can
alleviate any anxiety you might have by
the things they don't choose to say and
enable you to cast one thing off and try
another you have to be allowed to fail
as an actor because even it's very easy
to get taught in your performances it's
very easy to play it safe it's a
difficult thing for directors I think
oftentimes with directors they've got
vastly less experience of making films
than all the technicians and the actors
around them you know a director might
make ten films in 15 years in 20 years
whereas all the people that are working
with them might make 50 in that time you
know directors will cast like-minded
souls who are going to get on they're
all very idiosyncratic and they they're
all quite eccentric and large and they
work their way and you adapt and work
with them you can never perfect what we
do there is no way I've never met anyone
who goes that's perfection I mean to an
audience outside of your work people can
think that that's the only way they'd
ever want to see that part played or
that moment done whatever but as an
actor and this isn't Mach humidity I
think it's just it just goes for all art
forms really the whole point is
perfection is unachievable so it's that
constant pursuit of the unobtainable
which is kind of magic really you know
and and and should keep us kind of
motivated to try better you know it's
the bakit thing you know fail again fail
better some people don't see any of
their films but I do think it's a good
it's a good learning curve really to see
what you've done and how it works and
what doesn't work you're making is a
very valuable
to criticism to condemnation to personal
slander there's so many other walks of
life where you are criticized so
constantly you are bad I hate that actor
gay said you know I hate that actor
strong words I think it's very important
as a human being but as a as an actor or
I'm sure it leads into the other arts to
to really take time to give yourself
counsel like really give yourself
counsel to not just believe what people
are telling you you are what they
observe to be your position do some
people are great actors but it can't
deal with the lifestyle because you're
constantly being judged and there is so
much rejection even for people who walk
regularly the drama school is a great
idea I really do believe that in theatre
is a fantastic idea it's two or three
years where you get to be in an
environment that is safe your
vulnerability is protected
nowhere in the professional world would
you manage to get 20 gigs in three years
playing you know all these different
characters you're there you're kind of
dare to feel I mean I was very lucky I
was I had a very privileged upbringing
but at the same time I would always
always always make sure that I
understood what it was that I was a part
of on what I wanted to be distant from
to just see lots read lots hear lots
experience life as well and just keep
observing really observing not just
looking and seeing but sort of observing
I mean it's really hard it's really
really hard it's a difficult job and
with all the success comes a whole new
load of problem so it's forever the
landscape of it's forever changing but I
just think persevere don't worry about
being famous or coming at a star just
just do as much interesting work as you
possibly can spread your net as wide as
possible and then more work will follow
you'd be take what you what comes your
way and that and for me that kind of
adjusting my myself to what I didn't
think I could do was probably the best
learning experience I had including
anything
the last 10 years
you
[Music]